[Music]
pre-covet
i was really out there with the people
with my family
just staying involved
love to entertain love to have people
over
i'm a mother of four grandmother of two
beautiful family i love my children and
my grandchildren
i got ill it was march
18th i got really scared because
i realized then this stuff was in my
body
and we didn't know anything about it and
the only thing that i was hearing about
covet was that people were dying from it
[Music]
and i didn't want to die my expectation
with recovery was
i would get better and i would be done
with it and that's been furthest from
the truth for me
[Music]
i'm in a wheelchair going anywhere
more than five feet i'm pretty much
bedridden
i still have heart issues digestive
issues
headaches dizziness low blood pressure i
couldn't walk
three or four feet across a room full on
set of asthma symptoms where i was
having two or three
asthma attacks a day i was athletic most
of my life
prior to copen i was working out doing
high intensity workouts
i'm just standing still talking and my
heart rate's up
and this kind of goes and waves it waxes
and wanes
the medical community thought that this
was one and done
meaning if you survived the infection
that you would become
normal and this is definitely not the
case now
the other thing that i think is
surprising is how many
organ systems that this virus is
actually affecting
pulmonary meaning the lungs cardiac the
heart
neurological and also
psychological
i can faintly smell it
my post-covet symptoms that i've been
experiencing
are loss of hair loss of smell
of course memory fog memory loss
joint pains in different places we're
at the loss as to what to do for some of
these patients and their severe symptoms
what worries me the most is the brain
fog
because my father he had alzheimer's
i hoped and prayed that i never would
have to go through that experience
because i watched my father go through
that experience not being able to
speak as fast and and be as sharp as i
used to
that is definitely something that is
concerning to me
i was very fit and healthy before i
contracted the virus
before the spring i was with my
partner's family
in norway and we were hiking up
mountains
on the west coast the most worrying
thing
through all of this has been they
haven't been able to find a reason
for why i've been so poorly
[Music]
i'm about to get on zoom with pastor
robert dixon
post covet symptoms how's everything
going with that how are you making it
through it's been a pleasure
just knowing somebody else like you're
not on the island by yourself
when i saw you put your um facebook post
up
about you dealing with covet and just
the extent
of how you went into details it was
really
good to hear and then it helped me to be
able to
share more about what i was dealing with
if i'm in the middle of a thought
i can be thinking of the word and just
will not get it right that's me
yes absolutely in regards to
preventing further decline i don't know
if there's anything that we can do
mostly because i don't think we
understand enough about the time course
and the ideology or the cause of these
symptoms
i fear that they will never get back to
baseline
we can't tell for now whether that's a
possibility or not
just had a heart episode coming down the
stairs my heart hit
150 beats per minute
i'm out of breath another trip to urgent
care
waiting to find out if we're gonna have
to go to the er or not
had another heart episode yesterday and
this morning
[Music]
everything that i'm doing now is to
get my body my mind back
to where i was before i don't want to
stay in the place that i'm in right now
because it's not a good place
mentally emotionally or physically
i exercise in the mornings i may not be
able to do
the full 30 minute workout but
i'll try to do something just for the
sake of saying that i that i am
continuing working on my body
i have to retrain my lungs how to
breathe correctly
instead of taking shallow breaths i need
to use my diaphragm
and my diaphragm is really weak so pt is
helping me
there will be more patients with
long-term symptoms so the need to
understand the disease is not only to
treat the patients we have now but also
the patients
for the future
the future for me with the side effects
that i'm having
is tomorrow it's not a year later
five years or ten years 10 years later
i'm trying my best
to do what i can within my power
with prayer my faith in god to get
[Music]
better
you